- [Voiceover] So we have a
rectangle right over here.
Let's say that we know that its area is
42x times y to the third.
So that is the area of the rectangle.
And we also know that the
height right over here
is 14xy and what we
want to do in this video
is figure out what the
length is going to be.
And as you can imagine, it's going to be
in algebraic terms.
So I encourage you to pause the video
and figure out what is
the length going to be
if this height is 14xy and the area is
42xy to the third.
Well, how do you figure out area?
You take your length, and
I'll just use L for length.
I'll put L in parentheses.
So you take your length
and you multiply it
times your height.
So let's multiply it times
14xy
and that's going to give you your area.
So that's going to give us our area
of 42xy to the third power.
So how do we solve for our length?
Well, we can just divide
both sides by 14xy.
So let's do that.
So, let's divide the left-hand side
and the right-hand side
by 14xy,
14xy.
Now on the left-hand
side, I'm multiplying by
14xy and dividing by 14xy,
that's the same thing as just
multiplying or dividing by one
so that cancels out.
So I'm just left with L or our length
which is the whole point of
dividing both sides by 14xy.
And on the right-hand side, I can look
at the coefficients first.
I could say 42 divided by 14,
and that's going to be three.
Three, and then I could say
well, x divided by x that's
just going to be one,
and then I have y to
the third divided by y.
y to the third divided
by y, that is going to be
y to the third divided by
y is going to be y-squared.
And then we're done.
Our length is three y-squared.
So our length is equal to
three y-squared.